des salariés qui refusent de baisser les
bras après l'annnonce de la liquidation
judiciaire une trentaine d'employés de
la fonderie mbf ont décidé de poursuivre
la lutte depuis lundi avec des voitures
ils bloquent l'accès au site de
saint-andré qui fournit des pièces à
renault les salariés attendent des
explications du constructeur automobile
principal client du site
il lui reproche de ne pas avoir soutenu
la reprise de leur fonderie
malheureusement le fait de se désengager
au fur et à mesure et de manifester en
tout cas ça non volonté d'accompagner la
seule offre de reprise a fait que mb f a
été liquidée et aujourd'hui on vient on
vient chez renault pour demander des
réponses des réponses toujours en termes
de pourquoi le pourquoi et aussi pour
que renault accompagne le projet de
reprise des salariés à travers une scop
comme on l'a pu l'annoncer il ya
quelques temps les salariés campent sur
le site et se relaient chaque jour
depuis le début de la semaine
leurs collègues de la fonderie du poitou
ont fait le déplacement pour les
soutenir
ils craignent également la fermeture de
leur usine un combat commun puisque ces
deux sons de deux fonderies d'aluminium
donc on nous dit partout que l'aluminium
c'est un c'est un métier d'avenir et on
comprend pas que la mbs en liquidation
aujourd'hui alors qui fabrique des
pièces pour les moteurs hybrides de chez
renault et ont des moteurs de nouvelle
génération
donc normalement ils devraient avoir du
boulot et ça nous inquiète aussi nous
pour l'aluminium porte parce que du coup
on peut supposer quand on construit la
même tendance mois ce jeudi les
militants sont assignés en justice par
la direction du site
elle leur demande de libérer l'accès en
attendant pour récupérer les pièces
nécessaires à la construction automobile
un hélicoptère se charge du transport
les salariés se disent prêts à rester le
temps qu'il faut pour être entendu la
direction est restée injoignable